If you were stuck in Disneyland
for prisoners where you're forced
to compete in games to the death,
what would you do?
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do
and how to be the death
prison in Deadman Wonderland.
This student is about to see everyone
he knows brutally die Ganta.
Here is a small town kid
living like any normal teenager.
However, his life
is about to change forever.
Relaxing with his friends,
this school day is going like any other.
And that's when he hears a creepy song
from outside the building.
He turns his head and notices a strange
figure floating outside the window.
Suddenly it sends a shockwave
through the classroom,
killing everyone in sight, realizing he's
the only one still alive.
He looks up and sees the strange
figure holding his best friend's
head in the air with her body.
Nowhere to be seen.
This red man closes in on scared
little Ganta, pushing
a mysterious diamond into Ganta's chest,
causing him to pass out.
This is terrifying.
That creepy smile makes me think that Red
Man enjoyed killing all of our friends.
And despite all this,
I think we could have gotten
out of this situation with some superhuman
reflexes at our disposal.
Now, it's not every day
we see some crazed looking demon
floating outside our classroom.
But in Japan, you never know
what can happen.
As we can see, that blast was pretty
damn strong and left everyone dead.
But if it were me,
there might be a slim chance
we could have survived. And here's how.
If I was one of these students
who wasn't protected by plot armor,
I would have run towards the blast
lying down against the wall,
underneath the exposed windows.
As this will be our best
bet to making it out alive.
There's no time to open the doors
and run like hell.
So this is literally our only option.
The blast itself was strong,
but it wasn't strong enough
to take out the actual building
structure itself.
This makes me suspect that this situation
could be dealt with something
similar to a bomb blast.
The first thing we want to avoid is any
flying debris attacking our pretty faces,
and particularly to me,
because I am gorgeous.
And it will also help subdue the effects
of the shockwave emitted from the blast.
The blast also looked like it had
the blast radius of a couple of grenades.
And knowing that
just one military issued standard M67
grenade has a kill
radius of between five and 15 meters.
That means there's no way in
hell that over 30 of these kids
are making it out of that classroom
in time with an explosion such as this.
So rather than run, stay low, People.
Ganta wakes up in the hospital
to a terrifying surprise.
He's now being charged with the gruesome
murder of all of his classmates.
And if that wasn't bad enough, somehow
there's video evidence showing the police
that he committed the murders.
This seals Ganta's fate as the police
sent him to the most deadly prison
in all of Japan.
Deadman Wonderland, a prison
theme parks designed for tourists
to come watch prisoners tear each other
apart in horrifying death games.
But Ganta is about to find out
that there's more in store for him
than he could ever imagine.
At orientation, Ganta learns
how the prison works, its scary rules
and terrifying punishments.
This is also where he meets
a strange girl called Shiro,
who reminds Ganta of his dead classmate.
The two become friends
as she shows Ganta around the prison.
But this is a prison and nowhere is safe.
And so Ganta almost immediately
gets himself into a fight.
Suddenly, an explosion
comes from the top of the prison tower.
A massive fireball comes falling down
and there's nowhere to run.
That's when Ganta hear activates his
special abilities for the very first time,
making a gigantic forcefield and saving
both him and Shiro in the process.
Some time later, Ganta here wakes up
with no idea of what just happened.
The doctor here tells him of
these prison collars
they're forced to wear providing GPS data.
Not only that, the collar is constantly
seeping poison into their bodies.
This means that every prisoner
is on a time limit.
And if they don't eat an antipoison candy
every three days, they will die.
But unfortunately for Ganta, he can't find
his candy to save his own life.
Ganta meets this new guy called Yoh,
and he tells Ganta about a dog race show
taking place very soon, which is a show
where participants get a free red bean bun
and the winner gets prison credits,
meaning that Ganta can buy himself
another life saving candy and avoid dying
if he wins with no other options.
And the only way to survive
is by joining a game
that is looking to savagely kill you.
Ganta signs up for the money
and the tasty red bean bun.
We need to address the whole poison
dog collar thing.
What are we, pets?
The fact of the matter is,
is that our collars deliver poison
to us on a consistent basis.
And that makes me believe
that it can only be done
through some sort of absorbent patch,
much like how a nicotine patch works.
The fact is, we can't read
the poison out of our systems
if we don't know
what poison is being used.
So I'd ask around, for starters,
maybe shmooze a nurse, for example,
and see if anyone knows
anything more about our callers.
And I say poison and not venom,
as venom can only be injected
via a needle bite or sting due to its
mixture of large and small molecules.
Which means we have some big problems.
But whatever the case,
we need to get a move on.
We don't seem to have any side effects
from poisoning yet,
like nausea, seizures
or trouble breathing.
But I wouldn't rely on no damn candy
to feel better, sugar free or not, as
a constant prolonged exposure to poison
and can have some permanent side effects.
Ganta at the races gathers
with everyone else and they kick off
as they near the first guillotine
challenge in the race.
Crossing a pair of swinging guillotines.
Got to think it's a nasty surprise
by getting cut immediately, realizing
the blades are real,
and that if he isn't careful,
he could get chopped in half right here.
Blood and guts follow as Ganta
navigates his way through this death trap.
People die left and right as prisoners and
viewers scream in terror and excitement.
It's a bloodbath, except for Shiro,
who isn't terrified at sea and Ganta enter
the bungee jump of death as she pushes
Ganta off the podium with her
as they fall to their near death, barely
avoiding being splattered onto the ground.
They then move on to the poof
with archery challenge.
Ganta runs over a bridge as cute little
owl archers try and kill him with arrows.
But luckily, Shiro cleverly manages
to help Ganta avoid all of the arrows
as they clumsily make their way
through this death track, but not before
jumping over the bouncing balls track
right above a sea of liquid asset body.
Parts of fly everywhere as prisoners
continue to get brutally murdered past
the spiky dodgeballs, tumbling bridges
and actual guillotines and flaming fires.
Ganta ensure will finally make it
to the last challenge, the battle royale,
where the last challenger
to hold the dead man ball at the end
is to be declared the winner.
Ganta ensure I'll put up a good fight as
they managed to escape the falling panels.
Lots of limber movements and quick
reflexes almost help God to win the game.
But at the last second,
he has to choose between winning the game
and saving Shiro from certain death.
And so he chooses to save Shiro,
ending the dog race with no winner.
OK, Shiro did do
most of the heavy lifting in the race,
but we have something
that no one else has.
Shiro herself and this
tall glass of Japanese milk
here is seemingly invincible to dying,
which means we're going to use her powers
of invincibility to keep us safe.
Now, for the first challenge,
Shiro isn't needed, but what we do need
is to slow the hell down,
since we don't seem to have a time limit.
Instead of running recklessly
through the swinging axis,
which is what everyone wants.
I would crawl through the center
of the pathway to reach the other side.
As we can see, the axes
make enough of a gap or tiny frame
to crawl through without a problem.
Now he can avoid getting a nasty cut
and rest easy, knowing
that he's not going to bleed out
any time soon for the long
bungee rope where you had to pick
between the longer or shorter rope.
We need to get a little more crafty
from the look of Ganta's fall.
He thought for a near two seconds,
calculating the speed of gravity times
the two second thought
they'd Ganta endure.
It means that we are roughly 64
feet up in the air, at least three times
the height of a survivable drop.
This means we would need some way
to break our fall, since Shiro
doesn't care about her life.
I'd be the best, worst scumbag,
and I would use her to our advantage.
You're welcome. I'd simply steal Shiraz's
cord and attach it to my harness
along with the second cord,
and then jump this way as I fall.
The shorter rope, a.k.a.
the safer rope due to his length,
would be the first rope to tie,
not breaking my fall
just before hitting the ground,
landing safely with the final boss.
There's no way we can win head on,
and this guy doesn't seem that smart.
So I would use his ego against him
to make him super overly confident.
And then forces hand by making him
super mad and charge add us like a matador
to a ball before dodging his charge,
making him fall to his death.
Later at his cell, Ganta
without any candy, sits
sadly, as he counts
the hours until poison kills him.
As without any prison candy, he's
surely going to die.
Fortunately, his new prison
friend from earlier Yoh enters and offers
him a new candy that he has this
cheers Ganta, and the two boys head out
to get some ice cream to celebrate.
However, their time to celebrate is short
lived, as Ganta sees the terrifying red
man who smiles wide
as he readies to kill more people
and he blasts everyone in the courtyard.
This angers Ganta, who, without realizing,
uses his new powers against man,
chasing them away in the process
and causing gotter to suddenly pass out.
Ganta later wakes up and finally realizes
that he has become the monster
he hoped to kill.
Finally, realizing his true powers,
he also begins to hear about rumors
of a mysterious place hidden
within the prison called G Block, where
the terrifying red man may be located.
Wasting no time.
Conto sets out to find G Block
by himself and on the way runs into Shiro,
who happens to know
where G Block is and sets out
to show them the way they also run into.
On the way there as well.
But the party stops
when they come face to face
with a murderous security robot who begins
to chase them down to kill them.
Missiles start flying as the gang
finally reaches G Block, where Shiro is
almost killed by the security robot,
but is saved by cool guy in shock.
Ganta tries to fight this mysterious
cool guy who Ganta thinks is the red man
who killed his classmates.
However, cool guy doesn't know
just what the hell Ganta is talking about
and tells him that there are hundreds
of superpowered people within G Block
with similar powers to him and Ganta.
We also finally learned that
Ganta's powers require his blood to work
and that he needs to bleed first
before being able to activate his powers.
Their conversation is cut short,
has some prison guards find them
and tuck them into bed, so to speak.
Hold on. Shiro here
seemingly knows everything
about this place
and has the luck of a black cat
with four leaf clovers.
So we need to start thinking of her
as the muscle around here, as we've seen
her strength, durability and agility
in action, especially at those death.
Games, and since she hasn't
been killed by her own stupidity yet,
and until we figure out our powers better,
I would player like a fiddle and charm
my way to her pretty little heart
and order her to dismantle
those security robots right after Yoh's
sticky fingers took it out earlier.
And speaking of dying, cool guy here,
while seemingly looking like a douche,
is our best bet.
And staying alive and figuring out
more information about this place.
And as much as I'd like to slice
his carotid arteries
with a surgeon scalpel, Hannibal style,
we need to play it cool and act
as weak and feeble as possible
because I'm a damsel in distress.
Cool Guy is the only one
who we know in G block and someone who
looks like he knows how to use his powers,
which is why we need to befriend him
and do our best not to piss him off
until we figure out our powers more.
In fact, maybe we could learn a thing
or two from him.
I do charm the skinny jeans
right out of him and get him over to
our side ASAP, maybe even having him
look into our poising collars more.
He's a certified super villain,
which means he'll know others like him
and maybe even Red Man.
So let's use him to our advantage.
Ganta wakes up to find himself
being trapped and examined
by the promoter of the prison,
the same guy who also acted as our fake
lawyer, planting false evidence
against Ganta, including that fake video
and who got Ganta sent to prison.
This is where we learned that
this promoter uses this prison
as a place to experiment on people
surgically implanting the seed of sin
into their body and eventually
turning them into Deadman who then compete
in superhero like death games.
The next day, Ganta is forced to fight
against cool guy in a death match,
but struggles to beat him
due to blood loss.
We find out that
this means Ganta can't shoot his blood
too much as just like any normal person.
Too much blood loss can lead to anemia
and a loss of function,
which sucks for Ganta because cool guys
powers are simply terrifying.
But luckily, Ganta manages
to pull a fast one on cool guy
and defeats him barely winning the match.
Ganta was pretty stupid
to go in as unprepared as he did.
We know blood is the main driving force
behind all of this,
so we should start optimizing our blood
glucose levels like actual athletes
and to make sure that we can function
optimally throughout the match.
As we know, glucose is a type of sugar
that our body gets from foods
and uses for energy.
And low blood sugar levels can cause
a variety of problems like weakness,
lightheadedness and dizziness.
This is why I would try to increase our
blood sugar levels before a death match,
making sure our body has
a steady state of energy throughout
without getting depleted.
Just like a heavy duty training session
at the gym before a death match,
I would fuel up with a meal made of a fast
acting carbohydrates around 15 to 30
grams, which can come from fruit juice,
white rice or even some kid's cereal.
Fast acting carbs
will help us raise our blood sugar levels
the fastest, keeping our levels
elevated during our death match.
Also, why is Ganta shooting his blood?
You are literally giving away your power.
If Ganta is maybe a hundred
and fifty pounds and shooting
a couple of shots of his Gotthard gun
makes him dizzy.
This means that he is losing between 15
to 30 percent of his body's total blood,
meaning every time Ganta fires
his Ganta gun, he waste 10 ounces
of his precious blood. That's a lot.
He should really try changing
to a bloodsport.
Are some blood boxing gloves or something
Ganta wakes up later and eats as candy
as he hears a girl scream for her
dear life being the Ozo freaking noble
one Ganta rushes to go save her.
And we find out that
this girl is another dead man with powers
who is a little bit crazy.
But turns out Ganta loves crazy
and he immediately takes a liking
to this crazy girl
as she convinces him to run away with her.
And of course, lovestruck
Ganta falls for it
and leads her out into the hallway
as crazy girl accidentally
injures Ganta's leg
just as they run into some prison guards.
And as fate would have it, these two
are to face each other in a death match.
The next day, they arrive
in the grand cage.
But as it turns out, crazy
girl here is a complete psychopath.
She said Ganta by entering his leg
the day before, meaning his chances
of beating her are slim to none.
Ganta doesn't have time to react,
however, as Yoh shows up and reveals
that he's the brother of the crazy girl
in the midst of all of the twists
and turns and crazy girl,
even managing to attack her own
brother, Ganta finally defeats her
and puts an end to it all.
After the match,
he makes peace with crazy girl
and bumps into cool guy who tells him
that he needs to learn more attack moves
than just using his Ganta gun.
Later on, Ganta bumps
into white haired girl who tells him
that she's part of a group of Deadman
that are planning to escape
and that they want Ganta to join them
at their bar headquarters.
We also meet the leader
of this group, Scarfy,
and that's when Deadman killer
Rockstar drops by along with a beaten up
Yoh and takes out everybody
with his special guitar gun.
Suddenly Shiro appears out of nowhere
and breaks Rockstars gun chasing him away.
Ganta is then introduced
to the entire resistance gang of Deadman,
all of whom plan to escape.
They have a bar in prison
like that is awesome.
But why didn't they put some type
of little security system
at the very least
right outside of their bar?
I mean, if this is your base
of operations, I would have at least
had some security guys outside
when discussing plans
and from the looks of
things, Rockstar’s eyes.
Are not shielded, which means we could try
to blind him temporarily,
at least as with any type of chemical
like alcohol in the eye.
This can cause corrosive effects to occur.
This means if we use any 20 proof
or more alcoholic vodka,
this could cause corneal abrasions
and eye scarring,
which can result in loss of vision
and even blindness in some cases.
So basically, I would make a run
to the bar, find some strong vodka,
and when filling it all over, Rockstars
face giving us enough of a head
start to either jump him, tackle him
or make ourselves bleed to use our dead.
Manpower's against him before
he has the chance to use that rifle again.
Or if anyone had a lighter,
we could have simply done it
like the Finnish did with their invention
way back and throw some Molotov
cocktails at him, meeting all the members.
Ganta visits the brains
behind the whole operation, Mr. Smart Guy.
He reveals to Ganta
that the plan is to escape
during the prison's inspection
week, when the human rights authorities
will be conducting
a visit into the prison.
This is a week when the prison will be
forced to ax all
nice and sweet and won't
be doing any death gameshows.
This makes it the perfect time to escape.
That is, if they can first take out
that special group of prison guards known
as the undertakers.
These guys are the worst of the worst
of the prison guards who specialize
in killing Deadman.
Ganta then informs
the group that his powers
didn't work against Rockstar earlier,
which no one believes as smart
guy shows them footage showing Rockstar
clearly dodging Ganta blood bullet.
But they don't realize
that this was their biggest mistake
and one that will cost them everything
with no one believing him.
Ganta angrily storms out
and runs into Cool Guy, where he learns
more about the dead man group
and their leader, Scarfy.
We also find out more about Scarfy,
tragic past and the grudge
to kill Rockstar who murdered his pregnant
wife years earlier.
Feeling bad, Ganta decides
to join in on the group.
Now the break out plan is on.
OK, this seems sweet in all, but trusting
the leadership of a guy with a huge chip
on his shoulder and something to prove
is a huge red flag.
Scarfy's intentions may be good,
but like any good leader,
I can't rely on him to ensure that he
makes the right decisions based on logic.
If this is personal for him,
which it is, he may slip up
and make moves out of emotion,
certainly endangering us even further
and risking the whole plan in the process
to ensure the integrity of this plan.
We ought to make
sure someone else is in charge with way
less invested feelings in this situation,
as their judgment is a lot
less likely to get clouded as Garveys is.
This is going to cost them
more than they realize.
The group goes back over the plan
with the intent to show the world
what Deadman Wonderland really is.
The plan is to sneak out a data chip
containing a bunch of illegal
things that the prison has done.
The group decides to split into two groups
during the alarms to confuse the guards
with one group going to
take over the control room and Ganta group
heading towards the service elevators
that lead to the exit of the prison
guards, as group will also be
carrying the data chip with them.
The group then sets out
alarm bells go off as they run into
another one of those pesky security robots
who nearly takes out the bridge
and savagely kills another dead man,
forcing white haired girl
to sacrifice herself in the process.
The group finally reaches the elevator,
and after waiting for
what seems like forever,
the elevators finally open up.
The gang rushes up only to meet Rockstar
had his undertaker army.
Turns out this was a trap
all along, cornered and scared.
The group tries to fight back,
but fails as their Deadman power's
don't seem to work
against the undertaker's suit,
which means Ganta was right
earlier about Rockstar.
It's a slaughterhouse
as Deadman get their heads chopped off
and blood spills everywhere, resulting in
almost every single dead man dying.
Rockstar then leaves
the last few alive as he has bigger plans
to add insult to injury.
Shiro finally shows up randomly and steals
the data chip from Ganta
and destroys it in the process now.
The only piece of evidence against Deadman
Wonderland is gone,
leaving the defeated Deadman survivors
to retreat back to the bar.
Well, that's just great.
Not only did Shiro destroy
our only evidence,
but somebody clearly betrayed us.
And this group of capable
Deadman did everything wrong.
They could have avoided the security
robot entirely if they sealed off the door
entrance to the bridge
after they went through it.
In fact, I would have sealed off
every room as we made our exit.
We're not coming back.
So there was no reason not to destroy
at least parts of our escape route
as we cleared every room.
This could have prevented
any robots and guards from following us,
or at least slowed them down
and kept everyone alive.
And speaking of entrances,
the only escape plan was through
one elevator and one exit,
which by itself is way too risky and loud,
which is to not say a loud and proud
prison escape is invalid,
as there are many examples of famous
loud prison escapes
like the one done by the famous Texas
seven, who, during a prison escape took 16
prisoners hostage
and escaped a maximum security prison.
However, in this case,
I think it would have been better
to be more subtle about it.
Like Ronaldo Silva,
a famous man who once attempted
to escape a Brazilian prison
by dressing up as his wife.
It's a good pastime you should trade with.
That just being said,
I'm not saying we should
dress up as our wives,
but I think we would have had an easier
time of getting through the prison
by dressing up as the prison
security personnel.
I would have seen if there was any way
we could have stolen and.
Undertaker uniform,
as that would have allowed us to hide
our faces and would have made
for a much quieter and easier escape.
And speaking of which, trying to sneak out
over 15 Deadman was too risky.
If their plan was to reveal to the world
the horrors surrounding this prison,
then I would have brought
only one or two Deadman with me to escape,
along with the data chip.
It's harsh, I know,
but it was unreasonable to expect everyone
to make it out of a high security prison
without some casualties or problems.
Or we could have even given the data
to the government officials
who were already within the prison
for inspection week, like Ganta.
You could have done this
prison escape so much better.
The group says defeated in the bar,
just as white haired
girl shows up from the dead
and looks like all is not over
just yet, as she hasn't
given up and has another plan up
her non-existent sleeve. Suddenly, Mr.
Smart Guy shows up and we find out
that he was working with Rockstar, editing
the fake video of Ganta missing his shot,
planting a bomb at the data chip
meant to kill all the Deadman
and betray Scarfy, who is now missing.
Suddenly, more undertakers
show up to kill all the dead man.
But luckily, cool guy springs up and tries
to cut the undertaker suits, but fails
as smart guy reveals to us that
the undertaker suits are made of oxidizing
accelerator's that conduct an ultra high
pressure of 20 pascals worth of shielding,
meaning the undertakers are able
to disable any dead manpower.
But cool guy, just like his abs,
won't quit and creates a new trick up
his sexy sleeve using a never before seen
special attack, a supersonic blade
cutting through the undertaker
suits and weapons at the speed of sound.
Let's take a look at the undertaker
suits really quick.
These guys are absolute beasts,
but we need to figure out how their
armor works really fast.
Basically, one mega Pascal is equal
to about one hundred and forty
five pounds of pressure per square inch,
meaning that the undertaker suits
and weapons have around two thousand
nine hundred pounds of pressure
shooting per square inch.
This type of shielding
is also achieved by what is known
as a worm eater, a type of small device
that is capable of stopping the powers
of Deadman by turning their solid attacks
into ordinary liquid.
This is how their armor works by using
his Deadman powers at the speed of sound
cool guy was able to cut through
the undertaker suits
without interference
from the worm eater technology, which
means this is the way that we beat them.
This makes me wonder how come no one has
ever bothered to talk to Cool Guy before?
He's clearly one of the strongest
Deadman here and figured out
how to beat the undertakers.
The least we could have done is given his
feedback on this plan before starting it.
Also, asking Cool Guy to train them
to beat the undertakers is not a bad idea.
I'm just saying they should have involved
him in the plan in some way, ideally
even convincing him to go along with them.
And of course, a prisoner in a prison
betrayed us. Shocker.
And as a leader, Scarfy
should have double checked the plan
and he should have checked
if the data chip had anything in it
or not, despite how nice everyone is.
We are in a prison, after all,
and they are prisoners.
And I doubt everyone here is as innocent
and pure like Ganta.
After Cool Guy defeats the undertakers,
he declined the offer from Ganta group
to escape, thinking he belongs in prison
like the savage stud that he is.
However, he does agree to help train Ganta
for what's to come.
Cool guy helps him
upgrade, has Ganta gun ability to get it
to shoot faster than the speed of sound
which Ganta soon learns.
And just in the nick of time, too,
as Ganta is about to be tested
to his absolute limit
in just a few moments.
Suddenly he sees on TV that white haired
girl and Shiro have been kidnaped
by Rockstar and are being held hostage
at the Undertaker's headquarters.
Wasting no time, Ganta sets off to find
their base, eventually reaching it.
However, he now faces a new problem
as Ganta suddenly becomes dizzy
and is already at his limit.
Looks like somebody
has been forgetting to eat his candy,
Dessie and only half awake.
Ganta barely manages to take out
most of the undertakers as Rockstar
reveals a destroyed and soulless Scarfy
now turned evil and vengeful.
He's alive, but might as well be dead.
And he now claims
life means nothing and nothing matters.
Scarfy, who's clearly lost his mind
at this point, tries to beat up Shiro
as a weekend Ganta protect her
and gets himself and white haired
girl to talk some sense into him.
This seems to work, however.
He gets shot in the chest by Rockstar,
and this causes gotter to freak out as he
then pulls out his new uber cool
superhero movie and uses his famous
and newly improved Ganta gun
to shoot and kill Rockstar
firing his blood gun at supersonic speed,
blowing more than a whole couple of holes
into Rockstar for the very last time.
All right. We did it, but Ganta yet again,
failed to plan ahead
and as a result, got his teammates,
Scarfy, killed in the process.
For starters, Ganta shouldn't have given
all of his candy to cool guy.
That was unbelievably stupid.
I mean, he could have kept one
and we could have
at least stopped by the kitchen
or even a damn vending machine on the way
to the Undertaker's headquarters.
As for getting to take our candy aside,
Ganta should have also
eaten before his next fight,
as we already talked about this.
Remember the golden rule?
The better the blood sugar
we got, the better the butcher we are.
You know what? I'm pissed at everyone.
Guys, we could have at least tried
asking for cool guy to help us.
Like I said earlier, where?
Even Yoh's batshit crazy sister
who he ran into right before we got into
the Undertaker's headquarters,
and speaking of which,
this was the perfect opportunity
for God to add his powers to grab weapons
from the undertakers as they took
some of them out.
And this way, we could have saved up
some of our powers for the main bad guy,
Rockstar himself.
And Ganta did everything right
with Rockstar somehow pulling a finishing
move out of nowhere.
But what I would have done is violently
push Shiro into Rockstar, right?
As I took out my Ganta gun, using her body
as a shield of meat, so to speak,
preventing Rockstar from getting me
with his guitar gone before blasting
both Shiro and Rockstar away, killing
both of them in the process.
Cold, heartless and totally unnecessary.
I love it.
With Rockstar dead
white haired girl and Ganta
gather around scarf
as he gives Ganta his candy before dying.
Shiro asks him if he plans to escape
with white haired girl
and the rest of the dead man.
But Ganta tells her that he can't leave her
a friend behind.
The rest of the Deadman escape as Ganta
and Shiro sit on top of the prison
building, looking out onto the skyline
as Shiro sings a familiar song.
Shocked, Ganta realizes that it's
the same creepy melody that he first heard
at school right before his classmates
were brutally murdered.
But he lets his suspicion slide, showing
us just how whipped Ganta really is.
And if you don't want to be wrapped around
Shiro fingers like a tasty reinvolved,
don't forget to subscribe, comment down
below and check out how to be playlists.